this brings up what's called panspermia
but it's one of these things that argues
that life could transport its way around
the Galaxy very easily just floating on
meteorites it doesn't solve the origin
of Life problem but given that's true
and given that life on Earth emerged 4
billion years ago you know how surprised
should we be in a Bayesian sense that we
don't see Life on Mars in other words
and you hope we don't see Life on Mars
more specifically I think it would be
bad if we found on Mars independently of
all of life because that would be
evidence that life is common in the
universe I mean if it happened twice in
our solar system it's got to be all over
the place and since we haven't seen any
advanced life unless you believe in the
UFO like it looks empty there right so
then there's going to be this great
filter somewhere between having
primitive life on the subplanet and
having Advanced life like our current
civilizations and let alone what we will
become if things go well